seahawks uh and the 49ers
and man we thought this one was going to
be differently here's pete
go differently here's pete carroll
talking about the star of the day dk
metcalf
he's just so freaking tough and and uh
whether he's
you know whether he's blocking guys or
whether he's catching the ball or
whether you know they smack him when the
ball arrives
and and he's standing over those guys
you know when they fall off of him
uh when he caught the ball on the
crossing route i started
screaming that they weren't going to get
him right from like when he was way over
there because he's just too fast
and and uh he just circled the whole
defense and put
the end zone out i think they touched
him that was a great play
we're so lucky to have him and have him
grown and emerging in such a
dominant football player it's really
something
it's going to drive him crazy defensive
guy through and through
to have all these weapons everything
that he hates about football he's got
now
in russell wilson and dk metcalf and you
know chris you said it all week
when they went back and looked at the
film of the loss of the cardinals they
had to have been beside themselves that
they didn't involve dk metcalf
more and there's a balance there you
don't want to make it into that
obj dynamic where the offense becomes
paralyzed by forcing the ball to a guy
who maybe isn't open but you know what
metcalf once metcalf not open
right look at the difference from last
week to this week 12 catches 161 yards
and two touchdowns
and uh this guy is he's not on his way
he's there he's one of the best
receivers
not the best receiver in the nfl yeah no
i i i mean agreed i
i think right now as they stand here you
know halfway through the 2020 season
that mike i think you're okay
go ahead say it he's the best receiver
in the nfl i mean if he
if i'm a quarterback he's the guy i'm
taking right now i'll just say that i'd
go oh
if we got one pick right now wide
receiver who are you going to go with
i'd go
i'll take dk metcalf that's just that
there's that plain and simple
you know yeah thank you mike you're
right i banged on the drum for it last
week i
they had to have been sick watching the
film from that arizona game on sunday
night football last week going
wait we let a team play man-to-man
against our freak of nature dk metcalf
this many times and we didn't attack it
dk metcalf is like that five thousand
dollar
chip you got it like las vegas if you're
johnny big baller right
that's what he is you gotta use you
gotta use it a little
you gotta put pressure with people on it
because if you're just going to let
people play one on one
you're letting them now cheat and take
away other things in your offense so
yeah you don't want to go like you're
saying obsessive right where you want to
just every play has got to be for him
like obj with the giants and all those
things
no but you want it to be the point to
where you make a defense go
really okay we let you play man-to-man
once the last series you're gonna do it
again and again and again
you gotta feed him until the point to
where you go no you're gonna have to
double him i'm sorry
oh and now you're gonna eat chris carson
up the middle and tyler lock it across
the field and those things
they have a great chip there and that
they
they didn't use it to its full extent i
guess with my horrible analogy uh
last week now but but the thing is
and and we've moved on but at the same
time i'd love to know how they
internally broke that down
and decided what went wrong was it
russell wilson
not looking his way was it the play
calls that were constantly
away from him was he deliberately a
decoy for that game and they thought it
was going to be a tyler lock game
look when you've got dk metcalf you've
got you've got a guy who
and it's too early to compare him to
randy moss i don't know maybe it isn't
he you but you've got a guy who
you have to get the ball to yeah and any
i remember when randy moss was in his
early days with the vikings it was a
given
any time there was single coverage on
randy moss
randy moss was getting the ball period
and they waited for those moments
when moss would be single covered and
he's getting the ball
period that's where dk metcalf is right
now anytime he's single covered he gets
the ball and
maybe a lot of times when he's double
covered he finds a way to get open
lebron james is taking notice
calling dk metcalf baby braun
uh hey look you know anytime you cross
over like that and players in other
sports are noticing your greatness yeah
there's plenty of great players in the
nfl but dk metcalf now has that special
aura
about him in his second season the sky
is the limit
everything that everyone saw in that
chiseled physique and we thought it was
too much we thought something wasn't
right
and there were the vague concerns about
the the injuries and he did have
injuries at mississippi and there was
concerns about his limited route tree
and
he's learned he's grown and maybe he's
in the perfect place to do it working
with russell wilson because i think
wilson understood what he had
and if he worked with it if he sculpted
it if he
just kept focusing on helping him get
better he would get to this point where
he is and now
i think about these two tied together
for the next 10 years oh it's a scary
proposition it
it is i mean i mean i really what i
think about you know i know you brought
up randy moss and certainly it's that
kind of i honestly think he's more t.o
than randy moss right
just with that physique and kind of when
he gets going those knees fly up in the
air but
i mean the touchdown pete carroll is
talking about
man that that's insanity in the
membranity i don't know
what to say i've heard
well okay well i mean he's going around
the edge almost
every ride receiver in football maybe
other than tyree kill
is not going to be able to turn the
corner there and go they're going to go
out of bounds or get pushed out of
bounds but he has the speed and body
control to still stay in and
you know again i don't know what
happened in the draft i'll say you know
i don't know what anybody was looking at
you know i know i've been wrong i wasn't
wrong about dk metcalf
you know and he was over analyzed mike
and i also think you know
in the nfl world too at times too oh
he's got a nose ring and
you know he dyed his hair a different
color that scares people off too
i mean the nfl's got a lot of
traditional base type of people there
but either way the guy comes in that's
stupid
in this day and age it's stupid i mean
and you get what you deserve
i remember alvin kamara at one point
saying that he was going to meet with
someone and oh the gm's kind of
conservative can you take the
the the thing out of your nose no i'm
not doing it good don't do it what in
the world this is not 1972
people although there may be reasons
when you look around to think that no
it it's it's good and that's what you
get if you passed on dk metcalf because
he dyed his hair
or because he's different in some way
that's what you get and then the
seahawks benefit from it yeah you're
right
they do and they're i mean it is like do
you set to your point mike it's the
perfect place he's got a quarterback who
is so humble
and will always give him praise and make
sure everybody does
pete carroll just you know you know he's
gonna feed that and love that and
everything about it too and hey
we got to talk about the seahawks yeah
they won the football game
dk metcalf was obviously the big story
of the day
but the seattle defense i got to give
them some love too
i didn't expect that type of showing i
did not i really thought that the 49ers
offense would have their way i mean
seattle's defense has been the worst in
football it's not even close
and there they are yesterday stopping
the run
harassing jimmy g causing a few
turnovers
so maybe they've learned something a
little bit too here how they want to
play i mean it's two weeks in a row it's
you know last week wasn't horrible
either they had some moments against
tyler murray
when they get jamal adams back maybe
they are going to be more of a force on
this side of the ball
yeah absolutely i mean that was the big
stunner for me the fact that
right the 49ers couldn't run the
football they couldn't implement their
offense the way they wanted to
and and now you've got injury issues on
top of it george kittle's got an ankle
problem jimmy garoppolo
left we've got a short week with the
packers coming to town thursday night a
team that the 49ers blew out twice last
year
at home and the packers will be talking
about their game coming up there
they're in greater need of a win on that
short week and they don't have the
injury issues so
uh yeah 49ers it's just every time we
feel like a team is moving very sharply
in one direction
whether it's good or bad it pivots
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports